il y à une personne que vous avez étudié
à l'école et que pourtant vous ne
connaissez pas vous a parlé d'austerlitz
de waterloo mais vous at on dit que
napoléon était aussi un scientifique
si je n'étais pas général en chef je me
serais jetés dans les sciences j'aurai
fait mon chemin dans la route des
galilée des newton en dix ans à napoléon
at il voulu paraître plus intelligent
qu'il n'était peut-être pas les
contributions à la science il en a fait
beaucoup dont certaines que vous
utilisez encore en 2021 on fêtera les
200 ans de sa mort alors à cette
occasion on vous propose de re découvrir
ce personnage légendaire comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu ça faisait quoi d'avoir
napoléon dans sa salle de classe
c'est difficile à imaginer mais oui
napoléon a été un enfant à l'école avec
ses amis dans la cour de récréation
louisbourg yens l'un de ses amis au
collège déclaré je changeais parfois
avec lui la solution des problèmes que
l'on nous donnait à résoudre contre mes
devoirs de langues il trouvé la solution
sur le champ avec une facilité
déconcertante
son ami va même plus loin un tacle en
séance un prof qu'ils jugeaient
incompétent incapable de lui transmettre
la passion des sciences ce qui aurait
selon lui a jamais changé le destin d'un
enfant aussi intelligent que napoléon
bon alors je dis à des gens mais ça
c'était conscience durant les autres
matières s'était pas fou c'est
uniquement grâce aux mathématiques qui
peut entrer à l'école militaire de paris
où il aura la réputation d'être le
meilleur élève de l'école mais aussi le
pire d'absence et des notes en matière
littéraire catastrophique n'oubliez pas
il est et corse et à son arrivée en
france il ne parle pas français mais un
dialecte de local
la légende veut même qu'il ait appris la
langue en seulement trois mois mais ça
c'est peu probable
il gardera d'ailleurs toute sa vie une
mauvaise orthographe et un accent
italien dont ses camarades d'école vont
régulièrement se moquer le surnommer
bâillonnée par ce que avec son accent il
prononçait son prénom
napoleone l'ancien prof d'allemand de
napoléon bord le détester car il préféré
s'enfermer dans sa chambre
à lire des traités mathématiques de
grands mathématiciens que de faire la
langue allemande
une priorité alors que napoléon était
absent de sa classe il aurait traité
d'ignorants que selon lui les
mathématiques n'allait copette d'autres
au contraire l'aimé beaucoup comme
pierre simon de laplace qu'il avait
trouvé brillant à son examen final et la
place c'est pas n'importe qui il a écrit
le traité mécanique céleste un ouvrage
majeur en cinq volumes qui a transformé
la projet aux métriques de la mécanique
développé par newton nous à 16 ans on
est encore au lycée mais lui fait déjà
partie des 58 élus à être autorisé à
passer l'examen du grade de lieutenant
en 2d toute école militaire
fondu en france en entrant dans l'armée
napoléon se prend de passion pour le
savoir militaire il apprend toutes les
manoeuvres et stratégies les
constructions de fort ou de trancher
vous pourrez danser alors que son
intérêt pour la science allait
disparaître un peu comme toi avec tes
amis au collège que tu as oublié des
potes tu t'en fait de nouveau la vie
continue et bien pour napoléon c'est
tout le contraire
napoléon faut-il vraiment un
scientifique même sur le champ de
bataille napoléon s'intéresser à la
science
il étudie tous les jours son rêve était
de constituer une équipe des plus grands
scientifiques de son temps comme lui fit
recrutant les meilleurs de son équipage
durant la campagne d'italie il va
draguer ouvertement les scientifiques
sur son passage le naturaliste lazzaro
spalanzani l'anatomiste antonio scarpa
l'astronome barnaba oriani ou le
physicien alessandro volta
il finira en 1997 par être intégré dans
le lieu le plus prestigieux des sciences
de notre nation l'académie des sciences
à l'institut de france lui le général au
milieu des cerveaux les plus brillants
de son époque
comment tout ça a été rendue possible
certains pensent que ce n'est pas
réellement son cerveau en fait il aurait
été dotée d'une forme de mémoire qui
rend la personne capable de se souvenir
de tout mais l'explication de la
réussite de napoléon pourrait être un
peu moins glorieuse il aurait un peu
triché quoi vous l'avez peut-être déjà
entendu napoléon aurait résolu un
problème mathématique le problème de
napoléon n'est pas très impressionnant
mais très pratique il permet la
construction de figures géométriques aux
seuls moyens d'accompagner leur que
normalement on devrait avoir une règle
en plus dans la géométrie classique
je vais vous expliquer très simplement
vous voyez ce cercle donnez-moi le
centre exact sans règles allez-y et
n'utilisait pas vous dois ça serait de
la triche bombe à napoléon a trouvé un
moyen il faut tracer une série de serre
qui se recoupent et un dernier qui
permet de déterminer le centre il
démontre salle ses potes la place
lagrange et monge qui sont parmi les
plus grands scientifiques français de
leur époque et général nous attendions à
tour recevoir de vous excepté des leçons
de mathématiques
voilà comment on rentre à l'institut de
france la douille c'est que ben
vous vous souvenez napoléon était en
italie pays dans lequel il a pu
récupérer quelques trucs dont un petit
traité de géométrie de rien du tout
uniquement publié là bas un traité qui
résout justement ce problème quelle
chance et s'est passé crème personne n'a
rien vu
c'est comme ça qu'il s'est mis ses potes
dans la poche pour entrer à l'institut
et avec des pointures comme monge la
place où la grange pas appuyer votre
candidature mais c'était plié d'avancé
après ce que je viens de vous raconter
c'est une des nombreuses théories des
gens qui détestent napoléon parce que
quand on compare le problème et la
solution proposée par le traité italien
baas et pas vraiment la même chose il ya
de fortes chances que ça soit juste une
coïncidence qui fusaient ce n'est pas le
seul exploit de napoléon on lui attribue
en effet deux choses la résolution d'un
problème le problème de napoléon dont on
vient de parler mais aussi un théorème
le théorème de napoléon encore une fois
c'est signé en résumant simplement le
terrain de napoléon te permet d'avoir un
triangle avec trois côtés de même
longueur à partir de n'importe quel
triomphe et à partir de ça tu peux
obtenir deux poings nommés point
napoléon
ouais ça sert pas forcément dans la vie
de tous les jours mais bon fallait le
trouver sur cette découverte
malheureusement là encore les historiens
se battent pour savoir si c'est vraiment
de napoléon ou non comme quoi même un
personnage aussi célèbre peut garder des
secrets
mais revenons à cette histoire de
napoléon à l'académie des sciences
comment ça se passe
eh bien ça lui a grandement servi dans
son désir de conquérir l'egypte lors des
préparatifs pour le départ ils jouent
aux quelques trente deux mille soldats
167 ce avant le but étant que l'
aventure ne profite pas seulement sur
les plans économique et politique mais
également au niveau scientifique et
artistique
bien que la conquête militaire et
finalement échouer l aventure
scientifique est un véritable succès les
savants français fui hier l'egypte de
façon encyclopédique leurs travaux
furent publiés dans une oeuvre
monumentale la description de l'egypte
l'inde épaisse scientifiques les plus
marquants de cette expédition c'est la
découverte de la pierre de rosette
il s'agit d'un fragment de stèle gravée
de l'egypte antique portant un texte
traduit en trois langues en rouge vif en
démotique et engrais parfait pour enfin
réussir à traduire l'egypte anciens
c'est comme ça que presque 20 ans plus
tard jean françois champollion fut le
premier contemporain a enfin pouvoir
lire les hiéroglyphes cents à pau lyon
pas de découverte de la pierre de
rosette du moins une découverte bien
plus tardive
mieux encore ce en à pau
on la traduction des hiéroglyphes aurait
pu ne jamais se produire car il a fallu
l'idée révolutionnaire de champollion
pour y arriver
un chapeau lyon qui dans sa jeunesse à
bénéficier d'une bourse d'études in
education au lycée impérial de grenoble
tout ça encore une fois grâce à napoléon
napoléon a encore aujourd'hui une
influence sur les sciences beaucoup de
choses que vous vivez existe grâce ou à
cause de napoléon par exemple l'école
telle que vous la connaissez le
baccalauréat les lycées les grandes
écoles et la notion de corps enseignant
c'est de lui il refonde les universités
de médecine et de pharmacie avec un mot
d'ordre le lire beaucoup voir et
beaucoup faire l'enseignement au lit du
malade
pour résumer beaucoup de pratique
napoléon oeuvre à pour une médecine
moderne en étant le premier à faire de
grandes campagnes de vaccination contre
la variole
pour atteindre son objectif napoléon
jugera la contrainte contre-productive
préférant l'information et prêcher par
l'exemple qui va faire donc vacciner
l'héritier impérial les enfants des
principaux dignitaires du régime
puis l'armée finalement la moitié des
enfants de lempire finiront par être
vaccinés l'objectif est accompli
éducation médecine napoléon ira encore
plus loin dans le domaine des sciences
ainsi le s'entourer de scientifiques
directement au sommet de l'état il
nommera par exemple le chimiste chaptal
au ministère de l'intérieur
napoléon avait beau être le chef
décisionnaires il était conscient qu'il
lui manque un vrai bagage scientifique
il était très en retard par rapport à de
vrais experts et c'est pour ça qu'ils
posaient des milliards de questions
demandait la définition de chaque mot et
cetera
c'est seulement après ça j'ai prôné une
décision il était acteur des réformes et
pas un simple spectateur
et c'est en ça qu'il était un vrai
scientifique on ne se rend pas compte
aujourd'hui à quel point cette époque
fut florissante pour l'innovation
elle se fait dans tous les domaines
toujours grâce à l'état où elles
portative conserves alimentaires
casseroles émaillé liste lead hygiénique
et bon marché pour les hôpitaux l'ère
napoléonienne et l'une des rares où la
recherche scientifique et lucrative plus
besoin de mendier un poste de précepteur
de faire sa cour au puissant de
rechercher d'hypothétiques partie de
noblesse la valeur scientifique suffit
le revenu d'un savant reconnue
correspond à environ 100 fois celui d'un
ouvrier reporter au smic on serait sûr
du sens qu'à moi les scientifiques
éminents rouler en carrosse posséder d
hôtel particulier à paris et deux grands
domaines en province c'est une époque
unique où les scientifiques étaient les
superstars les artistes
et les footballeurs d'aujourd'hui
l'hégémonie française était telle que
marie sommerville scientifique et
traductrice anglaise disait j'ai prouvé
quelques mal à suivre les conversations
en français
mais lorsque l'on parlait science
c'était beaucoup plus facile car tous
mes livres de science était en français
finalement se développe un nouveau
domaine scientifique
les sciences appliquées en gros les
ingénieurs il donnera un statut
militaire à l'école polytechnique et une
devise pour la patrie les sciences et la
gloire faisant de l'école d'ingénieurs
une des meilleures de la nation vous
souvenez au début de cette partie je
disais grâce mais aussi à cause car tout
n'est pas rose dans ce cas laissé naples
et où il a fait de la science une
nouvelle aristocratie plus que jamais
elle est devenue élitiste quasi
inatteignable à la majorité de la
population
l'école polytechnique par exemple
deviendra payante avec des frais annuels
très élevé il y ajoute une épreuve de
latin au concours d'entrée rendant
nécessaire le passage par des lycées
spécifiques
autant vous dire qu'il faut avoir des
parents qui très tôt vous prépare à
cette école ce qui fit qu'encore
aujourd'hui elle est réservée à la haute
bourgeoisie aristocratique alors tout
dans napoléon n'est pas rose pour
beaucoup de repas nist convaincu sa
figure doit être détruite vous qu'en
belgique des pièces célèbres sa défaite
il aura volé la souveraineté du pays
tout entier en causant sur son passage
la mort de millions personnes
bien sûr qu bicentenaire de sa mort en
2021 ces débats seront mis sur table à
napoléon fasciste classiste esclavagiste
et colonialiste certains voudraient que
ses 200 ans soit sa dernière
commémoration avant que sa fille du raja
mais disparaissent de l'histoire loin de
nous notre idée de le défendre de
l'attaqué la fin de sa légende sera
aussi morne que les paysages de l'île
qu'il a vu mourir mis dans cette
ambiance de fin de règne
on voulait rappeler ses efforts à la
science domaine qui j'espère échappera
la politique
dites nous ce que vous en pensez si je
termine là d'ssus c'est aussi pour vous
puissiez en discuter calmement en
commentaire grand merci à spag jeunes
historiens pour nous avoir aidés sur la
vidéo allez les amis chaud
[Musique]